[Music]
the cancer genome atlas or tcga
is a landmark cancer genomics program to
molecularly characterized over 11 000
primary cancer
and matched normal samples spanning 33
cancer types
the joint effort between nci and the
national human genome research institute
began in 2006
bringing together researchers from
diverse disciplines and multiple
institutions
over the past 15 years tcga has
generated over 2.5 petabytes of genomic
epigenomic transcriptomic and proteomic
data
the data which has already led to
improvements in our ability to diagnose
treat and prevent cancer will remain
publicly available for anyone in the
research community to use
all data collected and processed by the
program is currently available at the
nci cancer research data commons or crdc
the ncicrdc is a cloud-based data
science infrastructure that connects
data sets with analytics tools to allow
users to share
integrate analyze and visualize cancer
research data to drive scientific
discovery
in addition to the tcga data crdc
also provides access to data from other
nci programs such as the therapeutically
applicable research to generate
effective treatments
also known as target and the clinical
proteomics tumor analysis consortium or
cptac
through various platforms these include
the genomic data commons
gdc the proteomic data commons pdc
imaging data commons idc cancer data
service
cds integrated canine data commons icdc
and clinical trial data commons ctdc
the genomic data commons gdc data portal
provides users with web-based access
to data from cancer genomic studies
the front page displays a summary of all
available data sets
the gdc data portal provides five
navigation options for browsing
available harmonized data sets
these include the navigations based on
project exploration
analysis repository or human anatomical
sites
each view provides a distinct
representation of the same underlying
set of gdc data and metadata
the toolbar available at the top of all
pages in the gdc
data portal also provides convenient
navigation links and access to
authentication and quick search
the left portion of this toolbar
provides access to the home page
projects page exploration page analysis
page
and a link to repository page the right
portion of this toolbar provides access
to quick search
manage sets authentication functions the
cart
and the gdc apps menu the project's link
directs users to the projects page
which gives an overall summary of
project level information
including the available data for each
project
it also provides filtering navigation
and advanced visualization features that
allow users to identify and browse
projects of interest
on the left a panel of facets allow
users to apply filters to find projects
of interest
when facet filters are applied the table
and visualizations on the right are
updated to display only the matching
projects
when no filters are applied all projects
are displayed
the top right side of the projects page
displays a few visualizations of the
data such as the top mutated genes in
selected projects
and case distribution per project
hovering the cursor over each bar will
display information about the number of
cases affected by the disease type and
clicking on each bar will launch the
gene summary page for the gene
associated with the mutation
users can toggle the y-axis of this bar
graph between a percentage or raw number
of cases affected
below these graphs is a table that
contains a list of projects and details
about each project
such as the number of cases and data
files
the table provides links to project
summary pages in the project id column
columns with file and case counts
include links to open the corresponding
files or cases in repository page
the graph tab contains an interactive
view of information in the table tab
the numerical values in case count file
count and file size columns are
represented by bars of varying
length according to size these columns
are sorted independently in descending
order
mousing over an element of the graph
connects it to associated elements in
other columns
including project id and major primary
sites
most elements in the graph are clickable
allowing the user to open the associated
cases or files in repository page
like the projects table the graph will
reflect any applied facet filters
the exploration page allows users to
explore data
in the gdc using advanced filters which
includes those on a gene and mutation
level
users choose filters on specific cases
genes or mutations on the left of this
page
and then can visualize these results on
the right
there is also a clinical tab with
filters that apply specifically to
clinical data
as users add filters to the data on the
exploration page
the results section will automatically
be updated
results are divided into different tabs
cases
genes mutations and onco grid
the cases tab gives an overview of all
the cases who correspond to the filters
chosen
the top of this section contains a few
pie graphs with categorical information
regarding the primary site
project disease type gender and vital
status
below these pie charts is a tabular view
of cases which can be exported
sorted and saved using the buttons on
the right
the case summary page displays case
details including the project and
disease information
data files that are available for that
case and the experimental strategies
employed
the genes tab will give an overview of
all the genes that match the criteria of
the filters
the top of this tab contains a bar graph
of the most frequently mutated genes
hovering over each bar in the plot will
display information about the percentage
of cases affected
in addition this section contains a
survival curve
the survival curve is calculated using
the kaplan-meier estimator based on all
cases with survival data within the
specified exploration page search
users may choose to download the
underlying data in json
or tsv format or an image of the graph
in svg
or png format by clicking the download
icon at the top of each graph
gene summary pages describe each gene
with mutation data and provides results
related to the analyses that are
performed on these genes
a table shows how many cases are
affected by mutations
and copy number variation within the
gene as a ratio and
percentage under the protein view
mutations and their frequency across
cases are mapped to a graphical
visualization of protein coding regions
with a lollipop plot
fan domains are highlighted along the
x-axis to assign functionality to
specific protein coding regions
the bottom track represents a view of
the full gene length
different transcripts can be selected by
using the drop down menu above the plot
the panel to the right of the plot
allows the plot to be filtered by
mutation consequences or impact
the plot will dynamically change as
filters are applied
mutation consequence and impact is
denoted in the plot by color
the mutations tab contains information
about one somatic mutation
and how it affects the associated gene
each mutation is identified by its
chromosomal position and nucleotide
level change
a table shows how many cases are
affected by the particular mutation
you can compare the effects of different
mutations on the survival curve
the exploration page also includes an
onco grid plot of the cases with the
most mutations
for the top 50 mutated genes affected by
high impact mutations
genes displayed on the left of the
y-axis correspond to individual cases on
the x-axis
additionally the plot also indicates in
each cell any cnv events detected for
these top mutated cases
and genes the grid is color coded with a
legend at the top which describes what
type of mutation consequence and cnv
event
is observed for each gene in case
combination
clinical information and the available
data for each case are available at the
bottom of the grid
in addition to the exploration page the
gdc data portal also has features used
to save and compare sets of cases
genes and mutations these sets can
either be generated with existing
filters
or through custom selection there are
three tabs on this page
the users can select either to do set
operations cohort comparison
or clinical data analysis the results
tab is where users can view the results
of current or previous set analyses
finally the repository page is the
primary method of accessing data
in the gdc data portal the individual
file can either be downloaded
individually from file summary pages
or collected in the file cart to be
downloaded as a bundle
clicking on the shopping cart icon that
is next to any item in the gdc will add
the item to your cart